good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast and happy friday friday
gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend friday friday getting
down on friday
happy friday everyone we did it not only
did we make it to friday we survived yom
kippur i don't know about you but i'm
feeling lighter physically emotionally i
do also feel like i've been hit by a bus
like i don't know what
maybe it's because i've never fasted
more than 30 seconds in my life but like
i guess some people like go a day with
like not eating a lot or like you know
eating every couple hours but me i'm
consistently eating and i just feel like
my whole body doesn't know what to do
yeah it's a lot i mean i
had a bit of a different experience this
year because i was eating but i was
trying not to eat in a glutinous way it
was like i know i need to wake up i need
to have a little breakfast and then i
had a little lunch and then like a snack
so i wasn't just like eating all day
because i could i still wanted to feel
the effects of what people were pain and
i do feel like i was in yo i made like
even though i didn't fast i was in yom
kippur that's really all that matters
that you were in it i was in it mentally
and spiritually so i do feel as though
i'm ready to move on with this year no
i'm definitely ready like i can't
believe that i'm on the other side of
yom kippur like i dreaded it for so long
yesterday i was like i'm going to make
the most of this weekend i'm going to
eat everything drink everything go
everywhere and now that it's ready i'm
like i think i'll take it easy this
weekend yeah but it definitely yom
kippur makes you look at food certain
foods like with a renewed spirit like
the things that you really missed you
know yeah well i of course you know
there was yom kippur but i had a major
other life development that on wednesday
i started downton abbey
and you guys
it's happening so
good like i am the i know everyone's
going to be like yeah we know we watched
it a million years ago what you have to
know about me is like i'm the most
stubborn [ __ ] on the planet and if you
catch me in a moment of weakness where
i'll like agree to watch something i
swore off
and like i like it like i will change my
tune but i'm stubborn and i like i'm a
creature of habit and i don't like to
try new things so yes i know i'm like
you know [ __ ] talking downton like my
whole life i take back everything i said
like it's so [ __ ] good like
and i just i can't say enough good
things about it you know like
shall i go fetch the linens like i can't
stop talking like that it's so good i
need to live in downton and i need to
marry the dad because like the dad is
the best character you think yes no he's
so good to everyone he's such a mensch
like he is a mensch but he's also kind
of like pretty dull no my favorite
character the dowager countess darling
the dowager countess is everything
everything of the sort like someone
needs to do a youtube compilation of
just hours your scenes most savage
moments most savage moments everything
that comes out of her mouth it's just a
pearl it is but my other favorite
character
is mrs patmore
oh my god of course the chaotic kitchen
energy
queen 100 percent daisy's my least
favorite character
that pat moore's always yelling at daisy
making daisy feel bad about herself now
they're becoming like a like a tag team
they are a unit technically um but pat
moore is just everything i couldn't like
nothing warms like makes me emote more
like positively and negatively you know
happiness which is going through a hard
time or happy times like when mrs
patmore's happy i'm happy when you get
more sad i'm sad so i'm like season two
episode four the episodes are very long
and very dense so it really is like a
treat and it's something you don't watch
when you're on your phone like i watch
it with subtitles just because i did too
i don't want like a joke
to and i was like you know what i watch
a couple episodes i'm like you know what
i think i can do it without the
subtitles and i turn them off and i was
just like missing good [ __ ] yeah i watch
with subtitles too when i watch um like
british stuff too because i don't wanna
i don't wanna not understand one thing
or think i heard something but it's
actually something else right and like
you just miss out and i watch subtitles
with the crown like
from start to beginning so i'm like you
know what let me just keep the subtitles
on i don't need to be too proud to use
subtitles and i'm just loving it the
thing is is that i'm watching it with
ben and he's like always doing stuff so
i do have to wait for him so it will be
a while before i finish it but i always
start shows and then like
with ben and run away with them so i've
decided i'm gonna keep this one okay try
your best but like if he's really
slowing you down like you have to watch
no he's like he's always doing stuff
like oh either he's working or he's
socializing he's going to golf having
lunch with his friends like i stay at
home
all the time you're a stay-at-home tv
watcher literally i'm a stay-at-home dog
mom and
i just feel like i should be able to
watch downton abbey i agree i'm so glad
that you're watching it i'm so happy
that you'll be like talking about it on
the show that way it gives me an excuse
to talk about it some more it's
literally the best show ever enjoy you
know what i'm so sorry that i wasn't
here for you when you were going through
your downton phase because like i would
have loved to have like went on the
journey supporting i mean like we could
have spoken about it like instead you
were just talking to a brick wall and
i'm so stubborn like you know i didn't
even care i i know and that's part of my
yom kippur like self-realization like be
interested in other people's interests
right because you're just about six
months behind also it's so moronic like
we should have went on the journey
together i know but and i try and tell
you these things all the time anytime
i'm talking about like my personal
interests i have no i have to speak as
quickly as possible so so you don't fall
asleep over there
and it's just like not only should you
you know maybe care a little bit about
what i'm what i'm into but just know
you're six months away from it no i know
i know and i'm so stubborn and like i
wish i could say that i'll change like i
really could but i'm so stubborn like i
probably won't
you probably isn't it good enough to
know that i'm like realizing acceptance
is the first step that's true but there
are other steps yeah so i think i've
checked off denial
now i'm in acceptance and i feel like
maybe that's where i'll stop
i think that's probably where you'll
stop too unless you want to hear about
the new york documentary by rick burns
i'm right now headed into the 1930s
so i was watching this docu-series um
i'm yom kippur it was it was heavy
especially because like i was in the
great depression there's a lot going on
um but it's really it's super
informational and once again i'm just
looking at my city within renewed spirit
and i'm really glad for that because
it's it's hard being a hater
actually it depends on who you are
because like for me it's so natural but
i feel like you're you're really like
naturally like a pretty optimistic
person so to channel that negativity
like to living in a city that i like
hate and just like being amongst these
like just it's negative you're drinking
the haterade it's so negative and so
this show is really giving me a more
positive outlook on my city and so
that's good yeah that's good and you
know a little bit of history never hurt
nobody no but also speaking of new york
i have made the smallest bit of progress
in seeing the snow by christmas i have
found i haven't even seen it yet but
online she found a listing she likes
okay but i just have to say like until
this point i haven't even found a
listing i like so that's how dire these
times are in the market show jackie she
thought it was great i'm going to check
it out after this
i mean i think it's it looks like it has
promised but it could also just be a
flop be good pictures yeah yeah and
there's like certain things that it
needs to hit that they didn't show
pictures of that i'm just like
yeah like there was a walk-in closet
where was the picture oh i'm not as
concerned about that it looks like a
nice size on the blueprint but the views
show us the views yeah yeah like what
are we looking for how much snow are we
seeing northwest east south is there a
building in front of us i hope not on
the airspace i would love to look at
literally an empty lot as opposed to
like a gorgeous skyscraper of course
because i need to see the snow before
christmas and if i don't i'm just
letting you know like check me into
bellevue because i'm gonna lose it yeah
okay we're working on it yeah we are we
are
well other than that it's friday which
is just such an amazing feeling um
congratulations to everyone for getting
here and if you fasted yesterday
congratulations on that as well yes good
you sure
yeah
and we have a great show for you i think
we should just jump right in we have a
lot to discuss you know not too much
happened while we were offline which was
crazy we weren't on our phones for 25
hours and it's like
what if something crazy happened i was
having honestly like a panic attack
about my phone i actually felt like this
year was the first year in a while where
i had a harder time not eating
no i had a harder time not looking at my
phone than i did with the eating like
i was just glancing over my phone was
off on my nightstand i just kept looking
at it like
does someone need me you know was there
an article written about me like i just
was having crazy and then i'm like
claudia and nobody cares about you like
you're fine um which did bring me
something people that do care about you
also aren't using their phones that's
true it was it was hard honestly like
i'm not gonna lie the phone was really
really hard usually i look forward to
the day off i think my addiction to
tick-tock has made it so that i i had a
hard time this year that's really crazy
i
totally enjoyed
not having the phone i checked my phone
like even just like to look to see if
someone texts me like i check it way too
much it's like nobody texted you you
know what i mean or then i just like get
caught like looking at instagram it's
just so toxic
honestly not being on my phone was
amazing that's so good for you i want to
do it more but because it wouldn't work
cause then everyone would just be like
worried about me it's like why aren't
you answering for eight hours no totally
you can't do that in this day and age
right but also like zach was my liaison
yeah so if you're looking for me just
reach out exactly or brew because he's
my personal secretary
if you want to reach him he takes the
most thorough notes i [ __ ] love bro i
love bruce so much she's the sweetest
cutest thing you guys and for anyone
looking for updates brew is doing really
well he's
so special he actually was at my house
yesterday because we used the same dog
walker and yesterday they went on a walk
together so i'm laying in bed and i hear
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is that and
i'm like thinking like is there someone
in my hallway and my doorbell rings i'm
like oh yes it's time for theo's walk
and i guess you know because we live
close to each other they thought that we
should walk the dogs together which is a
brilliant idea and i opened the door and
bruno just came leaping into my arms
full of gratitude
full of joy full of empathy full of
sass and it was honestly the most loving
embrace i've had in so long
and honestly i've been thinking about it
a lot like i just thought it was the
most amazing moment like
of my life and then he just like ran
into my apartment and we're like no
bruno it's time for your walk but it was
so
i wish i had a better vocabulary to
really like put a word no i'm being dead
serious no like joyous but what's like a
like for joyous like ten times joyous
like ten times like bursting like
what's the word for that i don't know
and also like we have totally like i
think our generation also like you and i
we totally just like abuse language
we're like we use such extreme words for
such mundane things like you say like
something that's two percent funny i'm
dying no a hundred percent so words
don't even mean anything anymore things
you know yeah i was thinking about that
and watching the documentary like there
were some quotes from like some poets
and they were like this like the
brooklyn bridge was terrific and it's
like but it was it
so it said something was terrific to me
now i'm like what was wrong with it
it changed the like the whole city the
whole world like
it was terrific we need bigger words now
because we just keep out doing our own
yeah so like
okay the 1930s was terrific like what's
the word for just like unbelievably
amazing and gorgeous and special
wonderful like it's just those are the
words glorious yeah
that's a really good point thank you
you're so smart
thanks claude okay that's a great note
to go on to the show
in two and thank you for the sweet kind
words about brew it means everything
it's a pleasure okay let's get into the
fast side stories that you do need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
away which is the most premium brand out
there whether it's a trip to the corner
store a weekend away or an extended stay
with friends and family we're all about
navigating the current reality of travel
but a matter of the destination or style
awaits suitcases bags and accessories
all come in a variety of colors sizes
and materials to suit your needs and
inspire your future travels so if you
don't have an away suitcase like you
ain't living they've literally thought
of absolutely everything and they're the
most like sleek looking you can always
tell like when somebody pulled you're at
the airport somebody like pulled their
suitcase like out of storage and i was
like that's literally ben um
because i use the away i'm like hey you
can just find one um you want to be like
a fabulous traveler who's just like
rolling through with their four wheels
like no problem away has all the
accessories that you need to make you
look sickening their wheels are the best
part they have four 360 degree spinner
wheels that guarantee the smoothest roll
even through the most hectic of airports
and stations
the bags come in a bunch of different
materials like polycarbonate aluminum
and durable nylon and they have tons of
different colors and sizes i of course
have the pink and i actually just placed
an order for a black one i feel like
it's time i like level up i totally
agree um they also have a tsa approved
combination lock that keeps all your
belongings safe and all their products
are designed to last a lifetime if any
part of your suitcase breaks their
standout customer service team will
arrange to have it fixed or replaced
there's also 100-day trial on everything
so
you take the product out on the road
live with it travel with it get lost
with it for 100 days and if you decide
it's not for you you can return any
non-personalized item for a full refund
during that period no ifs ands or
asterisks and they offer free shipping
and returns on any order uh with the
contingency in within the contingent u.s
uk europe and canada start your 100-day
trial and shop the entire away lineup of
travel essentials including their
best-selling suitcases at awaytravel.com
toast that's awaytravel.com
toast to start that 100-day trial
chicken thank you for that claudia away
travel is really the only way to travel
no i'm actually taking a trip
to uh the british virgin islands in
october and i'm thinking like do i go
pink or do i go black oh yeah it depends
on the vibe sometimes you just want to
be serious yeah no i'm going for the
weekend but then like i'm going with
brian and he was like we should do
something before because like where
we're going it's like difficult to get
to but if we go spend a few days on some
other break it up it'll make it much
easier for us so i'm like
so excited to go on my like best
friend's trip with brian because
traveling with brian you guys like
everything it's just the two of you yeah
oh because ben's gonna be in sonoma
working on spritz and then he's gonna
meet us in the bvi's so for that
beginning part it will just be the two
and then you'll have the threshold the
throttle yeah but like with the two of
us like there's
literally nothing compared to the energy
like me and brian when we're on vacation
and i don't know where we're gonna go
i'm just gonna like go where brian says
but i just know we're gonna have the
best time like we're definitely gonna go
to the casino and snorkeling like brian
just like knows how to live yeah totally
you need to be on vacation with someone
like that someone who just wants to lay
on the beach all day like no so i've
been going on vacation my whole life
with you yeah and ben and all we want to
do is lay on the beach yeah so when when
i first took a trip to a beach with
brian he was like all right so what do
you want to do today i'm like
for two weeks i'm like what else is
there to do and he planned we went a
beach drop we went snorkeling like it
was the best trip of my life like that
we spent like five days in
virgin gorda like some of course i never
even heard of the hotel or the island
show up nicest hotel i've ever stayed
out of my life if you're ever looking
for like a nice alternative to the
maldives for your honeymoon
rosewood little dicks bay that's the
real name little dicks nice except when
brian arrived it was big dick bay
are you ready to get into the stories i
am our first is some big news just as
for the girls simone biles is speaking
out against the entire system that
enabled and perpetuated former olympic
gymnastics doctor larry nassar's abuse
on wednesday the gymnast joined fellow
athletes michaela maroney maggie nichols
and ali raisman as part of a panel who
testified at a senate hearing on the
fbi's handling of the nassar
investigation spoiler alert they didn't
handle it whatsoever right the four
women allege that the fbi made false
statements in their official report
which they say failed to document the
survivor's claims mckayla moroni said
she spoke to the fbi and they wrote a
report 17 months later full of lies
right they didn't they didn't write the
report they didn't report the abuse that
she
came forward with and when they finally
did over a year later there were false
claims full of misinformation what is
the point of the fbi if you're not
protecting
our girls so like that's the thing when
i watch like all these documentaries at
the end of the day of course the people
who are perfect like the larry nassar's
are 100 to blame of course but there are
all these systems in place like that's
what i always think of um
the gabriel fernandez documentary which
is literally the worst documentary in
the worst story i've ever heard and it's
not like this boy who who died of abuse
from his parents it sounded like it
wasn't reported like uh child and family
services they knew about it they visited
the home like it's not like there was
nothing they they couldn't do anything
because it had never been reported they
knew about it it's the same with the fbi
and the iron answer thing it's like
these systems are constantly letting us
down it's like what's the point what's
the point
it's so frustrating yeah and you know
the fbi is to blame here
larry nassar is the line but so was usa
gymnastics where is the accountability
big time and so that's what the girls
were saying in their testimonies and i
mean
we said this during the olympics when we
were talking about
some of this but also hearing them speak
to the senate and like they all had
their prepared statements and really
detailed the abuse that they suffered
like it's not just larry nassar who
needs to go down for this it's the whole
system it's the whole system and i just
like i
that is just the craziest thing to me
that like these girls who are who are
representing our country who are
you know
terrific
in every single way terrific and they
are suffering abuse and they come
forward with it and there's no one there
to protect them no and then what you
think about like what they've been
through from like the sense of the
olympics like all these girls who who
testified are like at the top of their
game the best in the world winning
medals for our country going through
that mental anguish of that which is a
lot like simone biles talks about it all
the time like having the pressure of the
world and then also dealing with this
trauma like you can only imagine what
was going through their heads and they
still succeeded and won medals like
these girls are so tough like like
michaela maroney said that larry nassar
abused her right before she went out and
won team gold
that's [ __ ] crazy larry nasser is in
prison correct yes but this here
this hearing um
is about the fbi's
complete ineptitude
what's the point no it is what is larry
nassar that great a doctor they had to
protect him like just get rid of him
all they used to do was fire one person
after one claim was made and they
couldn't even do that right and it was
it's the worst possible claim child
abuse right the worst
and just like i met like and i can only
imagine what it feels like to also be
like one of these girls parents like you
and trust usa gymnastics and these
professional coaches
doctors trainers in in their hands
because there are so many adults around
right and you think nothing like that
kind of travel with you they go
international it makes me just think
again about this if there are so many
corrupt people in usa gymnastics who
haven't gone down for this and the usa
gymnastics team went to
tokyo this year without their parents
right
right right
no it's so twisted and i love all these
girls for speaking out and i watch the
videos and it was so sad because like
all of them just like want to be strong
but like they
and they are but like they get so choked
up like talk it's first of all it's so
personal like talking about your trauma
in front of like a room full of men like
it's just
weird and i just think that they're
amazing and i'm so annoyed at this whole
story and i think
literally like i hate them all and death
to larry nasser yeah and to anyone else
who heard about this abuse and and did
nothing right not only did nothing but
acted like against the girls and
protected larry nassar and
wrote false reports for the fbi right
but i was just thinking like anyone who
heard the abuse and didn't call 9-1-1
but that's the fbi
and they buried the report no literally
it's so crazy and then you think like
how could this have gone on for so long
and it's actually very clear how it went
on for so long nobody did anything right
people were coming forward nobody did
anything and you just i feel like so
many times we've reported on stories
like this where there's like abuse
ongoing for years so many people know
about it nobody does anything about it
and it's just like
what what are you people doing no
moronic
are you ready for our next story sure
switching gears a little bit a little
housewives crossover bethany frankel
claims tom girardi owed her late ex
dennis shields five hundred thousand
dollars i heard about this she said it
on her podcast right she's mentioning it
all she's mentioning it all
bethany frankel claims she's known about
tom jordy's financial woes for years as
he allegedly owed her latex dennis
shields 500 thousand dollars
the former roni star said during the
latest episode of her podcast
that she met the disgraced lawyer at a
lawyer's conference a few years ago
frankl claimed she talked to tom at the
time about how his then wife erica was
flaunting their wealth on beverly hills
bragging about everything from the 50
000 she spent on glam to owning two
private planes she said in my
experiences especially with housewives
if someone's flaunting their money they
don't really have it after that meeting
frankl claimed shields told her that
gerrard owed him girardi owed him money
he owes me half a million dollar dollars
bethany claimed dennis told her i know
this other guy he owes a million and a
half dollars to he doesn't have money he
owes everybody money oh my that's
[ __ ] crazy i mean it's so easy to say
stuff like that like once everyone knows
that tom is like a delinquent but um i
totally believe this like
and bethany actually really does have a
unique perspective on the housewife and
i remember she did she was on the cover
of like fast company and she did
a whole interview and a lot of it was
about like housewives and money and she
is right like when you think of like
the most like
is gaudy the right word like
ostentatious yeah i think of like the
early teresa years i think of jen shaw i
think of erica jane and when i think of
like who are probably the richest
housewives like i would say kyle
or like crystal a lot of the beverly
hills ladies they're not ostentatious at
all like they dress very nice they have
nice homes but they're not always being
like yeah we have two planes you know
yeah when you talk about it yes i agree
but also again in hindsight it's easy of
course to point out the people who were
talking too much and i'm sure it's easy
we could we could find someone who's
very you know
ostentatious with their money and has no
body problems but honestly someone i
mean like dorit
darit is very like
money well i feel like i don't know that
she's ostentatious about money it's not
like she's always talking about anything
other than fashion well no like pk had
you know got her bentley and and oh
right for the show if she jumped off the
boat or something she was gonna get a
birkin yeah and like you know they had
that big house that jayla used to live
in but it was a rental like
i don't know i think there's something
to it she could stop that [ __ ] though
she should she that was like season one
to read and like nobody was here for her
okay okay i'm just saying she doesn't do
that stuff as much anymore no but she
does have concerning financials pk is so
funny and open about his financial
situation like saying they were like you
lost a billion dollars in real estate
he's like no i lost 2 billion
as long as their money troubles are
behind them i appreciate that attitude
but considering he's able to talk about
it and laugh about it i have to believe
it's behind them yes but if i'm trying
to try to think of like a housewife
who's so out there with her money who
actually has the money to back it up
hmm
trying to think of like different
franchises yeah
honestly tiffany moon was like very yeah
like big house big closet big everything
clark wine cellar and she had the
the chops to back it up her husband they
own that random hotel like she yeah no
that's really good that's a good one
yeah so it's not always the case no but
i would say like more often than not
yeah i would agree with that and bethany
can sniff it out yeah but it's also like
i don't know
but i think it's just like a little
condescending when it comes to the
housewives
yeah she is and also like speak up
beforehand like right eric was at the
top of that so you knew
share the information
oh dennis 500 knowledge is power yeah i
know but like easier said than done you
know yeah also i'm sure like you hear
rumors about people and they're also in
the housewife some of the rumors are
true some are false so like you're not
they don't bring them up about each
other you know what that's true it was
the worst kept secret in la that he had
really issues yeah that's what she said
you know what rumor was true
ah deleted my twitter
how does it go after that the room was
the truth i deleted my twitter um i
started no that's not next but yeah
that rap that miley did when she deleted
her twitter was i would say top 10 like
most important moments of our lives as a
family like
we were so shook first of all like that
she deleted her twitter second of all
that she released a song and a music
video about it like we were quaking in
our boots on youtube like really true
margaret knows every single word
yeah to that rap that's really true
those were the days like miley and mandy
and then they started beefing with
selena and demi like
take me back such simple times truly are
you ready for our next story sure less
simple so some royal family news prince
philip's will will remain secret for at
least 90 years to protect the dignity of
queen elizabeth
so confusing yep his will is to remain
secret for at least 90 years to protect
the dignity of the queen and other
members of the royal family a london
judge has ruled sir andrew mcfarland the
president of the family division of the
high court made the order on thursday
according to multiple outlets mcfarland
who has not seen or been told of the
wills contents other than the date of
its execution and the identity of its
appointed executor ruled that a private
process can be held after the 90-year
period to determine if the documents
should be unsealed the bbc but then they
won't care that's i think that's that's
the point yeah quote i have held that
because of the constitutional position
of the sovereign it is appropriate to
have a special practice in relation to
royal wills there is a need to enhance
the protection afforded to truly private
aspects of the lives of this limited
group of individuals in order to
maintain the dignity of the sovereign
and close members of her family yeah
like in case there's some major drama
they can't afford any more scandals
right like say there was in there like
i'm giving it all to my mistress right
or my you know other kid right i hate
you william i'm giving it to harry
something like that like i guess yeah
well that means that there's stuff like
that in there or or there's not and they
just like want to set a precedent like i
don't really feel like it's our business
like who prince philip is like leaving
his money to right but it's not public
money right it's like their personal i
guess so because the public stuff gets
passed down to through the family of
course that no one really owns the
public money that they have but they do
have a lot of private wealth yes and
also the people who are getting it are
still getting it they don't have to wait
90 years no of course we just won't know
about it for 90. i think that's fair but
you're entitled to some modicum monica
my privacy totally especially in death
100
and in money like it's nobody's business
well the stuff that's like taxpayer
funded of course of course no those
financials
can and should even in america like when
like we pay for like
the fbi politicians like we know what
they do like you know you know they were
saying comparing how many vacation days
like politicians take we know because we
pay for it that's fine personal wealth
like they own like real estate
personally they have like huge estates
and like
bank accounts and trusts and yeah that's
their personal business they also come
from like long
families long lines with like you know
maybe some personal jewels like downton
like downton yeah everything i think
that's fair this is a fair rule i think
this is a fair rule at first it confused
me i never thought of the need for it
but
i think that's nice so then i think
maybe it's like to set a precedent
because if
not if but when queen elizabeth
sails to the other side um i'm sure
they're not gonna wanna yeah divulge
that information crazy we'll never know
what's in there and it's probably for
the best unless the crown does a season
on it and
gets some insider info
yeah that's really crazy to think about
how much money do you think he had
i don't know a couple mill i think a lot
yeah he seems like you know he probably
invested yeah and he's been around for
one thousand years well he was it's like
in twilight they lived so long right you
know they invested in the rails he
bought like one stock of apple like 50
years ago he's a billionaire yeah but he
didn't have alice's
power seeing into the future well i
always think like if i could time travel
i would literally like put in my
great great great grandfather's like
stock portfolio
a thousand shares of like
the railroad or whatever like disney
like something i don't know whatever it
was back then and like leave a note on
their
dresser like never sell this oh my god
that is like this book that i read
called
oona out of order
where after her 18th birthday every
birthday her birthday's at uh new year's
eve she jumps to a different age in her
life so she goes from 18 to like 52.
she's terrified and then yeah no in the
first time but if she goes back down she
can put some and so when she goes back
to in the past she is extremely wealthy
at 52 because she leaves notes for
herself based on what she learned in the
future and she's it's really funny that
is really funny yeah so that aspect
that's what i would do yeah no really
smart and you ever see that like meme
that goes around like this one guy in
1985 about like 20 shares of like a
thing named apple for like a hundred
dollars and a couple years later he sold
it for like thirty thousand dollars but
now it's worth like 300 million dollars
yeah wow
moronic
okay next story an update about
something we spoke about the other day
oh wait sorry is it the next story
that's brought to you by babel
yeah it is that's so good to know
because i was worried yeah you were a
little slow on the pickup well i just
was
sorry
i was honestly just thinking about how
people keep commenting how i keep saying
moronic a lot yeah and it's true and
it's really not my fault like when i
spend a lot of time with brian like i
just start talking like him is that a
word that he says yes and remember how
like a few months ago every other word
out of my mouth was like twisted and
turned
yes that's brian too like when i and i
just came off like spending a lot of
time with him and he's like
moronic and so now i say it so i'm sorry
but that's neither here nor there when
discussing babel when you're traveling
to a destination where you don't know
the language it can be challenging to
accomplish even the simplest of tasks so
if you're traveling abroad you want to
go to italy you want to maybe meet a man
order in a restaurant you've got another
language because it can be embarrassing
and hard and you want to be like cool
thankfully there's babel the number one
selling language learning app through
babel's bite size lessons you'll learn a
new language skill that you can use
actually in the real world from
greetings menus and directions to
gaining a deeper understanding for the
culture babel is a travel essential
honestly it's the smartest thing you can
do because first of all of course you
want to immerse yourself in the culture
of where you're going but also just for
safety when being able to ask for
directions and just like being in
control of where you are in a foreign
country it's really important to have
like a grip on the language so if you're
going somewhere planning a fabulous
holiday you know vacation you want to
see the snow in rome i don't know if
it's known in rome you got to check out
babel they have 15 minute lessons and
they make it the perfect way to learn
the new language on the go their
teaching method has been scientifically
proven to be effective and they have 14
different languages like spanish french
italian german and they have speech
recognition technology that helps you
improve your pronunciation and accent
start your new language learning journey
today with babel and right now when you
purchase a three-month babble
subscription you'll get an additional
three months free so that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com and use the promo code
tmt that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code tmt to get that six months for the
price of three babble language for life
thank you claudia it's a pleasure
okay our next story uh the activist will
not be airing as planned on cbs that's
for the best due to the backlash even
though i would
like have kind of like to see it and
like cringe you know no i want to just
like go see like see celebrities like
think they're helping yeah but now it is
shifting to a documentary special at cbs
because the backlash was about the
competition format okay the five-week
reality competition series had planned
to have six activists from around the
world compete to bring quote meaningful
change to one of three urgent universal
causes however cbs announced on
wednesday that the show will now be
reimagined into a documentary special in
response to the harsh criticism from
activist communities on social media so
instead they will just be highlighting
all of the activists
and not where does julianna fall into
play and not pitting them against one
another i don't know what this
documentary will now need three
celebrity hosts priyanka chopra also um
you know put out a statement she did
yeah for
you though
for
being out of touch yes exactly anywhere
from usher
um i haven't seen but that doesn't mean
that i just feel like a lot of these
celebrities like i don't know why i just
think usher like somebody offered him
like a job and he was like yeah sure and
like he didn't i think that's what
happens most of the time yeah
but that's what your management is for
like somebody on julian hof's team
should have known that this was not
gonna be the best idea for her yeah i
don't know i sometimes like
just people don't see it you know you
need like you're too close to it
and then
it everyone else is like oh no yeah and
then especially like if you're in like
the hollywood bubble like it's very hard
to see outwards right and it's like
we're doing like and considering they do
all of this sort of initiatives that
most of the time we read as tone deaf
but they really don't ever see it that
way it's like why now why this
initiative initiative totally why now
why this tone deaf initiative i totally
agree yeah so that's the latest so it's
going to be on what
the
c yeah i think i'm sure will be wherever
the other one was going to be which was
cbs paramount plus this is like such an
embarrassing stain on cbs's record like
they really should have scrapped it all
together but you know what it's nice to
give activists a platform so that's good
but it's just embarrassing maybe in the
end it will be
for the best for the best and now like
the show definitely has more buzz
so
yeah they say no press is bad press but
i don't know i just don't believe that
this yeah no but in this instance like
if there was just a show about like
activism honestly like i don't think a
lot of people would have watched no if
there wasn't even all this public
criticism but just privately people were
like that's a dumb idea yeah you know
nobody would have watched but now with
all of this hubla hoopla
it definitely brings eyeballs to it and
also everyone's like wait i want to see
what they did here that was so terrible
now people's curiosities have peaked
yeah even me i'm like i'd like to see
some of that show
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
no
yes it's the final story
[Music]
oh that felt good that did feel good
all the tension in my muscles it's a
little historic space news because it's
just sen oh hsn historic space news yes
spacex has launched an all-civilian crew
on inspiration for mission oh my god
jeff bezos must be like [ __ ] having a
mental break okay he definitely is but
he actually publicly like supported elon
musk this is a spacex initiative of
course he has to like appear to be a
good team and he's also like he wants to
appear to be you know a rival in the
space
space right right in the space i'm sure
it made news that he like congratulated
he was exactly so but anyways it's not
about jeff bezos it's about elon and the
four civilians who are making history
because an all-civilian crew shrieked
into space atop a spacex falcon 9 rocket
on wednesday which was the first first
privately funded non-government trip to
orbit a historic three-day flight
devoted to raising 200 million dollars
for saint jude children's research
hospital strong oh he should compete on
the activists yeah now that's some good
activism strapped in along with
billionaire jared isaacman who chartered
the mission were chris sambrosky an
everyday aerospace engineer sean proctor
an artist educator who will become only
the fourth black woman to fly in space
and haley arsenau a saint jude cancer
survivor who now works at the hospital
oh it's a beautiful story it's a
beautiful story there's actually a
documentary on netflix that just dropped
that's like chronicling um all of these
people there are four i think they don't
know each other like random people a lot
of people applied and they chose
for people to go to space three days
chilling
that's crazy and come home crazy the
people were so excited i didn't watch
the documentary but i watched the
trailer they were up in their emblem
space for three days yep they're they're
still there you're lying what are they
doing up there watching tv watching
earth
for three days i feel like you get up
there in like 20 minutes like okay
they're
being a part of history for three days
no for sure but that's a long time like
because then i'm thinking like let's say
just
you know someone you know came to you
and said i'm chartering we're gonna
you're gonna be the first redhead in
space and they said to me clutter you're
gonna be the first that person in space
i think i would say no like well i mean
not even because the three days of
boredom even if it was just like jeff
bezos like go up and come down i don't
have no i would do that i don't have a
taste for such things no i'm sorry i
would do the go up and come down in no
question oh my god no i would literally
have a heart attack like no i do you
would never first of all oh my god of
course i would no you wouldn't oh my god
by the way i probably wouldn't want to
do it but you can't pass up an
opportunity like that but the idea of
spending three days in a tight space
with people i don't know that i would
pass on right for you but like to take
the journey how long was the bezos thing
all in all 20 minutes i don't know
probably like an hour
you would never
no i 100 would how could you say that
literally never it's
historic
it's just
that's crazy stuff it does feel like
jeff bezos and elon musk are like having
you know like a pissing contest with one
another but i mean jeff bezos doesn't
even complain bezos was like i'm gonna
have the oldest and the youngest person
in space when elon's like well i'm gonna
have a cancer survivor like they're just
like going at each other yeah no but
this one is more historic first of all
because it is the three days it's not
just going up and down which is like no
offense these days anyways
apparently yeah um
but also this does sort of pave the way
for like private civilian space travel
which is definitely cool you know always
like to see us blazing into the future i
just don't think i you know i'm gonna go
to space in my lifetime but you know i
could be eating those words one day
everybody's going to mars my friends are
all going i'm really not going to go
right no like the fomo
i think i would be fine
that is just like i'm good on earth
earth is enough for me
dayenu
i'm not gonna lie like i feel like i've
met everyone i'm gonna meet on earth and
i've done you know i've hit all the
clubs i'm gonna hit on earth like i'm
ready to hit the clubs on mars no i just
feel like if i ever get that they're
probably out of this world
if i ever get that itch to you know see
something like i'll go to greenland yeah
for sure
there's so many places that you know
could transport me i don't feel the need
to go to space but maybe i'm alone in
that
and i'm ha but i'm like i think this is
so cool i think we're all space travel
and you know always you know blazing
into the future and just like and
innovating you know yeah we've got to
step it up no offense like there's been
so much innovation in the last 200 years
saying like our generation like i just
would like to see more so you don't
realize it because it's happened very
slowly we are so like we are basically
robots like with our phones like because
i wouldn't call that like positive
innovation though i like the fact that
we're robots with our phones but the
fact that like the phones are integrated
into everyday parts of our lives we're
literally so technologically advanced as
human beings yeah
because like i'm watching downton and
it's 1912 and like they're all just
getting phones and they're like afraid
of electricity so in a hundred years not
only we're not afraid of electricity
anymore like we are electricity
yeah no but in those hundred years like
so much has or it's like even in the 50
years after that so much
changed in terms of technology i think a
lot has changed in our lifetime i think
just really the
the switch from like cell phone to i to
a smartphone no think of it that's
because that's what we use every day but
like the xerox machine like there's so
much technology
faxes
scanners but those were happening like
in the 80s but they're so much better
now but it's not new invention 3d
printing
i haven't used it
it hasn't affected me that's a you
problem you've used it oh i 3d print on
the daily i'm just saying everything's
definitely been improved but like no
i've been the latest and greatest
recently no i think that you only feel
like
the cars are gonna be no no not just
because i'm living in it i think so no i
just think like
there hasn't
been
just like groundbreaking
there's always improving you know always
getting better but still at the end of
the day we're using a cell phone we're
using a telephone which is what the
technology already exists i hear what
you're saying yeah but that's what you
could say about it like the light bulb
it was just a candle but we improved it
oh i got you not at all
i owned you
so hard
um before we finish today's show it's
been a while
and it's time for a little kelly's
mindless news like the 4th of july now
today's kelly's mindless news is
particularly mindless and it's brought
to you by olive in june
the manny system the answer to the salon
perfect nail at home so olive in june
they have the best polishes first of all
and then they sell a whole manicure set
that will get you
tip top shape a buffer nail oil
literally everything you need so their
polish which is the best colors last
over seven days and they do not chip and
then with the manning system each
at-home manicure comes out to just two
dollars which is crazy because you can
probably do them yourself but they're
not very good and they look like they
were painted by a five-year-old but
going to the salon you know once a week
is super expensive and they always chip
so the olive and june manny system you
now you know how to do diy nails at home
that looks salon perfect and that last
over seven days
so
the mani set uh itself comes with the
best cuticle oil you'll ever use i
literally sit in bed and just put
cuticle oil on my cuticles nail file
buffer all the tools that you need and
they have this amazing like plastic
topper that goes on top of their nail
polish bottles and it
i can't explain how and i can't explain
why but it just steadies your hand when
you're painting your own nail i guess
that's a really good new invention
perfectly said jackie you know it really
does and also they have the best nail
polish remover like yeah you just stick
your finger in swirly
yeah and pull it out and your nail
polish is off and if you want to get 20
off your first manny system use code
toast with your new nail life you are
going to be feeling your best and get
that 20 off your first mani system when
you use promo code toast at olive and
june.com that's oliven june.com code
toast now back to kelly
kelly ripa is
dazzling in a whimsical dress that katy
perry would love okay question mark okay
this better like i could i could
envision this dress jackie according to
hello magazine were obsessed
one thing the fashion obsessed love
about kelly ripa
is the versatility of her style the live
with kelly and ryan star can wow whether
she's pairing a pair wearing a pair of
silky high-waist pants a mini dress or a
casual workout set so it was no surprise
that the daytime tv host dazzled yet
again when she walked out to the show
set on thursday wearing a dreamy printed
dress from the celebrity love danish
brand
stein goya
the dress which kelly first wore in july
of last year features a figure
flattering waist tie and a kelly paired
look with suede nude sandals it's a
great staple piece to have on hand since
it works well as a transitional piece
and can be worn in the fall spring
summer or cooler days is this kelly's
mindless news or danish brand stein goya
mindlessness let me see the [ __ ]
dress so wait this dress better rock my
world wait where does katy perry come
into all this you ask
kelly is just the latest star to rock
the popular brand katy perry has also
sported the designer ensembles as have
kendall jenner hailey bieber and more
and i just want to say the dress that
katy perry wore from this brand might be
the cutest dress i've ever seen in my
life
oh super cute but it's also just like um
and then this is what kelly rip is
wearing like art teacher vibes i i
honestly kelly robert i'm sure has a
beautiful wardrobe this dress is
particularly heinous and the fact that
it made news not only that but they
dragged katy perry into this no but like
it's just a dress that you would wear to
the workplace she's wearing it on live
with kelly and ryan it's not like she
was on a red carpet wearing like i when
you said this dress i thought maybe what
were you doing like what lily reinhardt
wore to the met gala right no she's
wearing an actual
dress a smock she's wearing a work dress
no it's a nice dress but like it's fun
are you going to write an article like
that about what she wears every single
day on her daily show imagine that we
write about what we're wearing today
stunning toast merch and beautiful
seasonal color available at
shopmorningtoast.com
not the not the pants what are those
sweatpants we almost made sweatpants but
then we decided to make shorts instead
because it was hot summer yeah it's a
summer collection and you guys said you
wanted shorts well i just wanted
everyone to know like we've checked in
with kelly she's still being mindless
and that's really all that matters and
we can go into the weekend at peace
knowing that mindlessness is keeping up
and you know what like
the world is constantly changing there's
just like so much going on but the
constant of knowing that like no matter
what day it is no matter what's
happening like a
news outlet will write something so
mindless about kelly where but it's kind
of comforting jackie the more things
change the more they say the more
kelly's mindless news stays the same
the more things she should actually like
the more kelly stays mindless no the
more things change like and things are
so crazy like the more mindless the
mindless news is because relative to the
craziness people are going to space and
kelly ripa gets just as much like
fanfare as elon and jeff bezos yeah it's
crazy when you think about it
so that is our show should go to space
and you know lay in her stein [ __ ]
address a hundred percent and you know
what that would be real news
no i look forward to the day we get an
actual piece of news the last major
thing that happened to kelly was
honestly probably her downfall like when
she stormed off set refused to come to
work because michael strahan her co-host
accepted a job offer for a better job
right
no i don't know if we've ever reported
on like one of these unless it was like
the slowest news day on the morning
we reported on the michael strahan stuff
okay but after that
but maybe now that you're saying that
maybe all of this mindlessness is to
push down that narrative people don't
remember like that she threw an
unbelievable temper tantrum and took an
entire week off like without telling
anyone just escaped because michael
strahan accepted a job on good morning
america
after being her co-host for a year which
like he's perfectly entitled to do
and she like ran away she makes 21
million a year she did not go to work
for a week and then came back and like
apologized to her audience and was like
you know what i've been doing the show
for you know 17 years whatever i'm
entitled to have my breakdown i'm like
actually you're not like you're not at
all like this is the workplace kelly get
it together like what was the issue
would she have wanted that job no i
think she was mad that he likes the kind
of thing i think maybe she felt like he
used her show as a
step to get to a better job
that's what jobs are that's what jobs
are no and i guess she wanted someone to
be a long
so what happened after strand did you
get another co-host or there was just
like a revolving door there was a
revolving door until right ryan yeah
heard ryan are good together yeah i mean
ryan might literally drop dead of a
heart attack any minute now because he's
the most overworked person in the world
and he literally does a morning show in
la and
no monday morning show in new york yeah
it makes no [ __ ] sense so justice for
ryan but i hope that he's in good health
because i do worry about i mean he makes
these choices you know nobody's for i
mean not that we know him no nobody's
forcing him he's not like you know like
britney spears when she was 17. he's the
executive producer like he goes out for
all these gigs like he wants more and
more and more like
that's the life he's chosen no you're
right he's fully in control of his own
destiny and he's
destined for this he chose work
yeah not even work like 11 works
yeah 12 jobs literally
so that is our show
that is our week hope everyone had a
good time today hope everyone's looking
forward to the weekend weekend thank you
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitch or public video i
have ready to cast box all the places so
if you listen to podcasts find us more
until sleep five starve you about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
if you've made it to the end of today's
episode congratulations you are now part
of the society season two to let us know
your true toaster who made it to the end
drop an emoji on our most recent
instagram pic of the dress to honor this
beautiful steingoy address that kelly
rip award bye everyone have a great
weekend